[Music]
[Music]
so
the uncertainty or understanding the
lack of knowledge is
actually what pushes us forward
[Applause]
we need to know whether it's not just a
question of more experiment or more
calculation
but also a question of expanding or
changing
the conceptual schemes with which we
look at things
[Music]
we know we have feelings and experiences
and yet our official scientific world
view tells us
there's just electrochemical signaling
in our heads
hello and thanks very much for joining
us for this debate the known
and the unknown for much of human
history
people have held firm beliefs about the
nature of the world
but now a steep decline in religious
belief compounded by
doubts about the possibility of
objective truth
has left many in the west feeling
profoundly lost
should we welcome this new uncertainty
and revel in the absence of a
constricting set of beliefs
or are we only now recognizing the
limitations of the human condition which
are hubris once
obscured or denied or
must we escape from being lost even if
it means
adopting illusory certainties in order
to provide
social identity personal well-being and
purpose and we have a very illustrious
panel to discuss this theme
we have renata celeccia who's a
philosopher and sociologist and is a
currently a professor
at birkbeck college and at the institute
of criminology in the faculty of law
at the university of labyana and she was
awarded the title slovenian woman
scientist of the year in 2010
and her works include on anxiety the
tyranny of choice
and forthcoming a passion for ignorance
we also have philosopher and writer
philip gough who's an associate
professor at
durham and his research focuses on
integrating consciousness into our
scientific world
view his book galileo's error was
published in november last year
and defends pan psychism as a solution
to the problem of consciousness
and we also have simon blackburn who's
an emeritus professor of philosophy
and fellow of trinity college cambridge
and simon is the author of many books
including think and mirror mirror
the uses and abuses of self-love
so in a moment i'll turn to each of our
discussants with
a opening provocation a question and
i'll give them each three minutes to
respond
then we'll have a debate among the panel
very roughly divided into three sections
which i'll signal
as we go along and then we'll have a q a
with the
audience so for our opening question
and i'll ask renato celectial to begin
renata should we embrace uncertainty
for three minutes thank you definitely
we can only ever embrace certain
certainty
and it was already medieval philosopher
theologian
nicholas the cruiser who you know spoke
about
the necessity of understanding the
limits of our
knowledge and you know his term dr
ignorantia learned
ignorance was a very important kind of
first reasoning about the necessity
to sort of understand what cannot be
known in his case
he was mostly speaking about god the
infinite
uh and i think that this kind of a
reasoning continues
to our days a few years ago
a very interesting book was published by
american scientist stuart feinstein
called ignorance how it drives science
so the uncertainty also the
understanding the lack of knowledge is
actually what pushes us forward on the
individual level
psychoanalysts know now for more than
100 years
uh that people claim rationally that
they want to know but actually they have
a passion
for not knowing in a way passion for
ignorance as jacqueline
psychoanalyst said but even more
importantly
psychoanalysts would point out that when
they encounter people
who actually have certainty who are
lacking doubt
then they start to question whether they
are maybe dealing with people who have a
psychotic structure so to have on a
personal level in our question about
yourself
who you are what do you want what do
others say
might be you know precisely the
uncertainty to which
we never find an answer and you know it
is an uncertainty which might be
painful but it is also an engine of
our drives our desires and
it is an uncertainty which we need to
learn
how to live with thanks very much renata
um i'll now turn to philip gough for the
same
with the same question philip should we
embrace uncertainty
thanks well actually rather than living
in a period of uncertainty i actually
think we're living through a period of
false
certainty there is a popular narrative
very popular narrative
according to which for thousands of
years philosophers tried to speculated
about the ultimate nature of reality
and then we discovered the scientific
method and the days of speculation
ended now i don't think anyone thinks we
have all the answers
but i think many people think we know
with something close to certainty
the way to go about getting them namely
through the scientific method i think
this kind of scientism is in many ways
the new religion now the the success of
physical science for the last 400 years
or so is
is phenomenal and and rightly celebrated
but in my view it has been so successful
precisely because it focused on a quite
limited task
roughly constructing mathematical models
to describe
uh predict the behavior of matter and
there's just lots of that's very useful
but there's lots of things
i think we know to be real that just
simply can't be fully accounted for in
that way
facts about consciousness facts about
maths and logic
facts about value and significance uh
now that's not the fault of physical
science it was never
intended by people like galileo to for
that for those purposes
but i think we're going for a period of
history where people are so
blown away by the the success of science
and the incredible technology is
produced that has such a visceral effect
on you
that we become inclined to think that
the story we get
from physical science is a complete
story of the whole of reality
and i think this leads to an incomplete
and impoverished
picture of reality we know we have
feelings and experiences
and yet our official scientific world
view tells us there's just
electrochemical
signaling in our heads we know that
human trafficking
is objectively abhorrent and yet our
official worldview tells us we live in a
valueless universe
and i think if nothing else i don't
think this is not very good for our
mental health
so i hope that as a society we one day
rediscover
the importance of philosophy um
the role of philosophy in my opinion is
to take what we know from
natural science but also things we know
to exist in other ways
facts about consciousness the reality of
abstract objects the reality of value
and to synthesize all these together in
a single
unified world view so i'm not sure that
would take us
to certainty but i think it would remove
a false certainty we currently live with
and thereby bring us a little bit closer
to the truth
thanks very much philip and finally to
simon blackburn with the same
question should we embrace uncertainty
simon
well i'm happy to say that uh to some
extent i agree with both of the previous
speakers
uh i agree with renata and saying that
um the impetus for science is
ignorance uh nicholas the cousin was
absolutely right about that
and that we do well to
embrace uncertainty if only as a drive
to inquiry and it's the
processes of inquiry which i think we
should all admire and those
especially includes the processes of the
very successful physical sciences and
those those aren't just
um i think the questions of mathematical
models i mean if you think of science
like geology
um people used to think the world was
six thousand years old
uh we now know that it's um something
well the universe is something like 14
billion years old and yeah
four billion years old so that's an
increase in knowledge it's not
particularly an
increase in the mathematical model but
it is an increase in the understanding
of the uniformities
of nature which we see all around us and
which enables us to enable us to
construct a timeline
i think that's one of the great
successes of physical science
but there are many many others one could
concentrate on
however i do agree with phillip that we
have to be careful about supposing that
the methods of physical science will
tell us everything we need to know
and i thoroughly agree that the methods
of philosophy are needed
as a professional philosopher got to say
that
that is we need to know when it's not
just a question more experiment
or more calculation but also a question
of expanding or changing
uh the conceptual schemes with which we
look at things
however i don't think that that is as
radical as philip perhaps
hopes it is uh there are many many ways
of trying to
um reconcile for example our knowledge
of right and wrong
with the physical world with the with
the conception of ourselves as physical
animals
i think there are many ways of doing the
same for mathematics itself
and logic and eventually i think there's
going to be
ways of doing it for consciousness
the phrase the heart problem of
consciousness has been much in the
news i think for no very good reason
because it's been there since descartes
um but i don't believe there is a hard
problem of consciousness i think the
only hard problem in the air is
in in the area is uh stopping thinking
that there's a hard problem of
consciousness
so so on that i think i disagree with
philip
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas